la la la we go First Merch of the video
potentially let's see if I bought any oh
damn it damn it damn it all right well
my Bando got sword sold off I was hoping
I was hoping I could buy one of these
cuz these things merch for an insane
amount I'll check them out on OS buddy
but uh yeah I was hoping I'd be able to
hit up one of these hey band's God Sword
ornament kit has bought so we're going
to throw that back on there I figure
I'll flip this just while I'm waiting
for the other things to sell I figure
why not so let's go ahead and keep on
doing this I guess what's going on boys
we're in the we're in the morning I
guess um as you can see overnight I was
able to sell off this band's God Sword
ornament kit which I ended up making
500k on um other than that I tried
buying some Anu armor CU those things
are really unstable right now and you
can make a ton of money if you're able
to merch them however none bought
yesterday none bought overnight so I
gave that up and now we're onto a ring
of the coins which currently has like a
little over a m margin and Saran gotw
ornament kit which is always a [__]
good time
okay this is the first big merch of the
series hopefully it goes well so
basically we just bought ourselves a
ring of coins which once I go onto the
OS buddy site and I look at the weekly
says I should be able to sell it on for
65 is so I'm going to go ahead and do
that I'm just going to list it up for
like
65 350 somewhere around there make a
mill on that if it ends up selling so
there we go let's go hey there we go so
sidan ornament kit has bought I'm going
to see what I can sell that on for and
then we're going to put that back up
there uh I obviously have the highest
sell offer and I think I could be able
to sell this for around like 159
hopefully I'm going to try to go for
something around there but uh we'll see
this will take some time definitely hey
told you it would sell look at that [__]
15.85 I bought it for 15 pretty much 15
on the dot so we made 800k on that
that's pretty lit I'm thinking about
here soon making progress videos with
this account I don't know though I mean
I'd make a ton of progress but I just I
don't know I kind of want to do
something with this account as a whole
if you guys have any ideas let me know
down in the comments down below kind of
want to do something I don't know could
be any sort of series I'll think about
it though if you guys have any ideas hit
me up hey there we go successful ring of
the
or successful ring of coins merch I
merched it for 450k cuz it dropped but
uh it is what it is we'll definitely
take that and uh yeah I do believe that
the price of it has dropped yeah the
sell price is down to 63 point 78 so I'm
going to try to buy one of these while
I'm gone playing soccer for I believe 60
I go
63 57k somewhere around there yeah let's
do that we'll try that out and uh see if
we can get anything off of that let's go
boys big potential merch here basically
the Anu gloves Buy price at least OS
buddy is saying right now is
22.7 MIL which means that that was the
last one that's been insta bought for
which means I think we can sell it for
more than that so I'm going to try 23.6
mil we're going to put it up for that
and I bought them for 20.1 which means
if these things flip that's a 3.5 mil
profit and I'm not I'm not too uncertain
that they won't flip to be totally
honest with you so I'm pretty hyped to
see what happens with these well figured
in the meantime I'd do some uh some
other merchesi I haven't merched a lot
the last couple days so uh I'm going to
throw these back in for
92k and as you can see that'll sell for
3.6 and I bought him for 3.3 really so
uh 270k profit even though I had to buy
and uh well actually I only had to buy
one whatever I know I had to buy and
sell one so I lost 80k all right some
big things have happened um just loging
on the account before I go to bed all
these Elder chaos tops bought and sold
250k profit as you know and C gloves
20.1 mil sold them on for
22.5 2.4 4 mil profit then mummy hands
which is a little different something
outside the box that I wanted to buy as
you can see the guide price says around
7.3 mil and I'm going to check the RS
buddy price could definitely be around
there so I'm going to check that out and
see what we can list it up for if you
guys wondering why I'm talking so soft
it is because my mom is asleep and it is
4:00 a.m. and I do not want to get uh
yelled at let's put it at
that all right all right so mummy hands
dropped to 3.667%
hope for the best hopefully these all
don't drop on me overnight is what I
mean by that oh my God boys are you guys
ready for this all those things I have
no clue what bought what's sold okay
that's fine we don't need the enq stuff
I'm actually pretty disappointed cuz
those are the big
merchesi as you can see I made
1.15 mil off of that and the armadel god
sword ornament kit could be something
that may drop on me because it has gone
up so much
um well it says it says the price of it
is
13.2 which is a little Annoying
however oh man I don't I don't know what
to do with it I think I might just sell
it on for a loss um take it for what it
is maybe basically the price that it's
sold at yesterday it hopped all the way
up to 15 mil and then dropped down to 13
mil then up to 16 then dropped to 14
then up to 16 so I don't I don't know
we'll see all right got really scared so
I listed up only fork profit maybe could
have made more but at least now I know
that I can buy it again for a lot
cheaper I'm going to go like 12.9
12956 and if this is able to buy then we
know we have an 850k merch on our hand
so uh let's go all right since
everything's sold off and nothing seems
to be buying I'm just going to go and
take out all these offers real quick and
we can see what our cash at at why not
let's check it out bang
95 mil pretty much on the dot insane um
I don't even know what we started that
this episode at probably like 91 92 is
so that's huge progress already this
episode well boys and girls why am I a
[__] boys and girls this uh this could
be a huge [__] up I don't know so
basically this uh bucket Helm is stable
around 82 mil and it says right now that
the last one that was in sold was for
884 and uh so I was like all right I'll
put an offer for 78.4 maybe it'll buy
obviously insta bought so I bought it
for 77.2 and I'm not really too upset
about it I honestly think I could sell
this on for like
83.2 and I'm going to see if I can
because I have a good feeling actually
probably going to do decently well it
dropped to 60 mil and that's really low
it was just a scare it's going to go
back up and I don't think there's a
whole lot of risk for this item to be
honest with you so we'll see different
now a different setup cuz I'm at my
dad's but we got all these Elder chaos
tops to sell as you can see we bought
most of them for 900k or 990 so I was
able to make pretty much 50k on six of
these so I made a quick 300K off of
those and uh yeah I'm hoping this Buck
out sells once I get done with these two
things I'm going to probably be going
back to more conventional things cuz
these clue scroll ones are kind of
grinding on me and they aren't good for
the videos cuz they take so long to flip
hopefully the the uh the kid cutting in
the background isn't isn't too much and
uh please don't copyright me but
nonetheless I'm a little nervous about
this bucket Helm G thought I had a good
merch going on here obviously I instab
bought it so at that moment I knew I
[__] up but I thought maybe we can
make something out of it and it's not
looking to be the way it's going to be
basically three of sold and only one has
bought in the last 4 hours and the last
sell price was at 7 23 mil as you can
see here that would be a 4 mil loss so
uh I'm going to list it up for what we
bought it for and just pray to God that
it sells overnight because I don't think
it's going to sell tonight so this is
probably the last time you'll see me
before I come back in the bucket Helm is
worth um 50 to 60 mil if I'm lucky all
right we got lucky enough to sell this
thing back off for what we bought it for
however and you guys are probably going
to think I'm think I'm done for this I'm
going to try to buy it for 73.5
so we'll see what we can do it's kind of
messed up but I think it's worth it but
I said that earlier so who
knows there we go boys look at that look
at that [__] all right so
72.85 mil I was able to buy one for the
price that I can apparently sell it for
is 70 oh yeah I'm going to list it up
for 77.2 because I was able to sell it
for that earlier so we're going to go
ahead and try that out I actually might
drop to like
76890 because my that price is the uh RS
Buy price so people are going to see
that but
76.9 and if we're able to do that then
we make four M and hopefully it doesn't
drop on us again this time I think I'm
going to keep it though all right may
seem strange I don't know the prices of
dragon stones at the moment however if
you look at Loop halfs and tooth hals
right now the total price if for insta
buy is 39K insta Buy price of Crystal
Keys should always be higher than the
insta Buy price of both of those or at
least the same and it is 1 and 1/2k less
so I'm just going to buy out all of
these Crystal keys that are at 38k so
we're going to see how many we can get
or maybe that was the only one and uh
I'm just going to be terribly wrong on
this and this entire clip is literally
for nothing but going to go with like
what 220 somewhere around there that
should do it uh one more yeah there we
go and I hate myself all right I don't
think my buckel sold cuz nothing up here
at the bottom right here hand corner of
my screen so it is what it is but uh
yeah that's depressing don't know what
I'm going to be able to sell this thing
for kept it in overnight granted it
doesn't I mean I wouldn't expect it to
really sell overnight cuz you know
that's the least amount I mean that's
the time where the least amount of these
are bought or sold and uh yeah I mean
the price of it is pretty steady I guess
um I'm probably just going to leave it
in for around 75.5 maybe I think that
that's what we'll do and hopefully it'll
sell while I'm at work which I'll be
heading off to here in a second so
uh it is what it is let's let's hope it
sells please a [__] me right God damn it
I just got back from work and I still
can't sell this [__] and two of them
have been bought oh my
God oh my God all right well I'm going
to lower it again I thought I could make
a lot of money on this apparently not
okay 758 or 74800
that's probably where I'll stop that's a
2 m profit and it should sell on for
that sometime soon I would imagine I
[__] hope cuz this has been almost
like 18 hours now with it and I'm not
trying to keep it for any longer at all
how y'all doing um yeah something a
little different I decided you know [__]
the buck alms and uh bought these for
3.4 it was like what 3.45 I believe so I
was able to make pretty much 2 point or
250k off each one of these so quick 750
50k made I didn't even have to buy and
sell one to find the margins so uh yeah
worked out pretty well for me I
accidentally took the offer out but I
ended up flipping another one of these
so we've made a mill off of these I
think that is about all we're going to
make since no more I've bought but uh
that's good profit while we got it if
this is able to sell on right now I'll
be at pretty much what 77 or 97 mil I do
believe well the meantime Has Come What
well here we are so I bought 10 Elder
tops going to sell them all on for
969k and apparently didn't [__] click
it but yeah so we're about to make
probably like 55k I think off of all of
these and so in total that means I got
550k obviously while we wait for this
[__] thing to continue to sell here
we go boys so basically what you're
going to need to do is just disregard
the uh the mass amount of things in here
this is all for my other account and uh
I was just using this account to buy out
some of the stuff so basically Elder
chaos tops have bought and as you can
see we were able to buy those for 9914
which means we made like 27k per one
well actually made a little bit more but
uh it wasn't it wasn't anything too bad
I always enjoy merching those just cuz I
always seem to have a decent margin
never anything outstanding but you know
something for a little bit of guaranteed
money what's going on boys and girls I
hate myself so this bucket Helm not
looking good last one that's been sold
sold for 63 mil which would mean i' lose
9 mil selling off this bucket home which
I do not want to do it's going to go
back up and I don't think there's a
whole lot of risk for this item to be
honest I have a good feeling that this
is actually probably going to do
decently well and hopefully it doesn't
drop on us again hello everyone yeah bet
you didn't expect to see me here this
early in the video but it's that time
and the video is coming to an end and
normally I have to do an outro at some
other point because these videos are so
pre-recorded as you can see by the price
of the items cuz bucket Helms right now
are honestly like 40 mil but uh yeah so
some interesting merch is going on that
episode um it was it was rough it was
rough I won't I won't tell you guys what
I end up selling the bucket Helm at but
uh we'll find that out in the next
episode um other than that basically I
have a couple updates that I want to
talk to you guys about in regards to the
series
So currently I have a plan for my main
account which is what I want to base
most of my series around however that
merching account I do love
um my main account is getting
dangerously close if you combine it with
my merching account to getting an Ellie
right now I'm around 655 mil and an
Ellie is 750 which you guys may seem to
like you you'd probably think that that
would be a long time before I'd be able
to get that however it is only 100 Mil
and with as much money as I have 100 Mil
actually comes a lot quicker than you
would think so basically what I want to
do is create a life or a life after
Ellie Series in which I rebu build from
an Ellie with literally nothing else
however I want to do that pretty much as
quick as I can so sometime within the
next couple weeks I want to start that
however I can't start that unless I have
the money from this merching series so
I'm kind of debating on what I want to
do if you guys have any suggestions feel
free to leave it down below I just want
to make a series on my main account and
I would love to keep the merching one
going at the same time however the plan
that I currently have going won't allow
me to do both at the same time at least
until I get pretty far into my Ellie
series and even at that point if I got
like all the money back which is I mean
you guys don't know yet but I only have
one more episode after this so it's no
more than 100 Mil and so if I want to
get that money back for my merch series
I would have to build up 100 Mil in the
Life After Ellie series and then throw
it onto my merch account and then just
pretend like nothing happened and have
to restart my life after Ellie Series so
I don't know if you guys have any ideas
as far as to what I could do I might
just stick with the merching series and
just try and get the Ellie on my main
account and have that be something we do
later nonetheless hope you guys enjoyed
this video If you guys did feel free to
leave a like if you guys have anything
you would like me to improve upon leave
it in a comment down below you like the
series you want to see more hit that sub
button cuz I will have more of this
series I love merching trust me I know
it's been a while since I've uploaded
but I truly do enjoy it so nonetheless
whoever made it this far into the video
just know I appreciate the [__] out of
you for watching all this and uh yeah
that's it for me today hope you guys
have a wonderful day and uh peace here
we go with the outro
[Music]
[Applause]
boys my true